The samplebased quantum diagonalization method or SQD for short is a quantum classical hybrid algorithm like Kryov
quantum diagonalization KQD like VQE and many others. In using such hybrid
algorithms, it may be useful to think about where each algorithm leverages quantum and classical computing. Recall that VQE creates states on a quantum
circuit using classically optimized parameters. In that case, the state itself is on a quantum computer. Though
obtaining the target state is a process that combines both classical and quantum computing.
The expectation value of the operator is calculated using quantum measurements.
But some classical combining of terms is also necessary.
In contrast, SQD uses a quantum computer to generate a useful subspace onto which the Hamiltonian or other operator can be
projected. The Hamiltonian is then diagonalized entirely classically to find the target state. Suppose we have a
problem of interest to science or industry that can be cast as an igen solver problem on a matrix of n rows and
n columns. Suppose further that n is large enough that exact classical diagonalization is not an option. It
would clearly be advantageous to reduce the dimensions of our matrix while preserving all the relevant features of the ground state. Indeed, that is the
goal of many approximate igen solver approaches, including classical kryoff methods. Let's assume that we know enough about our problem to make a
reasonably good guess about the form of the ground state, but not enough to solve the problem outright. In that
case, we could make many measurements of our fair approximation of the target ground state. The results of these
measurements give us a subspace of computational basis states that contain all the relevant components of our
ground state. Projecting onto that subspace would yield a smaller matrix that still contains the relevant degrees
of freedom. The workflow for this is as follows. You start by choosing a good
onzot. More precisely, choose an anzot whose support coincides with that of the target state. We'll discuss exactly what
that means. Next, measure the state in the computational basis as is done with the sampler primitive.
Then, use the results of the sampling to define a subspace that contains the ground state.
Then, project your matrix onto that subspace. Finally, diagonalize the smaller projected matrix classically.
Let's pick apart each of these steps, paying special attention to defining the subspace.
Throughout all of quantum computing, choosing a goods is always critical. In the case of SQD, your choice of ANSOT
will determine what computational basis states may be measured in the sampling.
The true ground state can be expressed as a superposition of some subset of computational basis states. That subset
is called the support of the ground state. To get a good estimate of your ground state and its energy, your anzots
must have a non-zero projection onto the computational basis states in the support of the ground state.
This diagram represents the space spanned by all possible states on the number of cubits being used. We want an
un anzot with support that contains the support of the true ground state.
Consider a very small example system with a ground state of s ground is8 *
the state 1 0 0 plus 6 * the state 001.
This has support made of those two vectors 1 0 0 and 0 1. Let's say the Anzots is of the form SNZOT 1 is A times
the state 1 0 0 plus B * the state 0 1 0 plus C * the state 001. So that its
support is the set of three vectors 1 0 0 1 0 and 0 0 1 a superset of the
support of the ground state. This is a good anzot.
Now imagine that we had instead chosen an anzot of the form szots 2 is a * the
state 1 1 0 plus b * the state 011.
This has support made of those two vectors 11 1 0 and 011 which has no overlap with the support of the ground
state. This is a bad anzot.
Note that we do not necessarily require that the unzots be a good approximation of the ground state. The unzots could
have much larger support or the coefficients could be very different on the anzots and the true ground state and still work well.
At this stage, we've used a well- motivated to make the quantum computer adopt the state similar to our target
state. Shown here is the unitary coupled gastro or UCJ unzots which is very useful in quantum chemistry.
We now want to measure the state of the system obtaining bitst strings describing the collapsed state of each
cubit. Recall that Hamiltonian estimation as in VQE requires many quantum measurements. This is partly to
reduce uncertainty and partly due to the number of groups of commuting Paul that make up the Hamiltonian.
In sampling methods, you still need lots of measurements, but the reasons are different. Now, we need many measurements to effectively sample the
many computational basis states involved in highly entangled quantum states. In SQD, the sampled bitstrings correspond
to configurations of the simulated system. If the system being studied is subject to absolute constraints like
conservation laws in physics or chemistry, then most of the measured states will be valid. But some sampled
bitst strings correspond to invalid or non-physical configurations due to noise and errors. A process called
configuration recovery aims to refine these noisy samples into a set of more accurate configurations.
This process involves generating new configurations by probabilistically flipping individual bits based on
averaged orbital occupancies and known particle numbers.
The refined configurations are then used to span subspaces for Hamiltonian projection and diagonalization,
iteratively improving the fidelity of the quantum state representation.
Let's look at a trivially small example of configuration recovery to understand its meaning. Suppose we measure a
quantum system with four cubits representing four molecular orbitals and obtain the following bitstrings from the
quantum processor. Each bitst string represents the occupancy of an orbital. One for
occupied, zero for unoccupied. Kiskit uses a notation in which the least significant cubit is on the far right.